how the [ __ ] did he get you that deal
[Music]
all right welcome back to off the record
where we talk about whatever we want
whatever we [ __ ] want
what do you guys want to talk about like
i don't want to talk about nothing all
right what do you think about nothing
what is nothing if everything is made of
atoms then
everything is something then something's
nothing you know what's funny
the whole reason for off the record is
because when cameras used to go off we
had
really [ __ ] good conversations true
we're like we need to do this [ __ ] and
it still stands
yes we're having very interesting
conversations we just had a very
interesting conversation
real cameras and they were like you know
why because some of the [ __ ] is i think
not interesting to them but it's very
interesting to us
yeah like the [ __ ] that we have to go
through with brands and all that stuff
but there's other things that are very
personal to us that we don't want to
share
true that i want to share with them but
some people won't be happy
yeah what are you not one sure that you
want to share now
[Laughter]
i share everything but i think uh
there's certain things that i want to
talk about that involves very personal
things that i think other people don't
want to get involved in
so those are the things i think are
really exciting why do you make it
juicier yeah you keep making it juicy
can you be specific
or or can it be less juicy but people
are nosy man we give up a lot of
information right so like yeah
all my live streams [ __ ]
kids would just be like is your dad dead
yet oh my god
well you put that out there i know it's
my fault right and you put it out there
in that tone you did i know you're just
bringing it back to that tone too but
since i put it out there that way
yeah they think it's okay yeah yeah and
then they throw it back
at me yeah but for me it's like pinky
i'm with you guys
it's fun because we're friends yeah but
they're strangers oh so
yeah you don't know me like that why are
you talking to me yeah i get that so but
they think they're a part of the joke
because they watch the video true
because you made the part of the joke
cause that's what they think they're
hanging with
people i don't know them but they know
you they hang out with you every day you
know them
it's not the same like if people watch
taiko every day right and we go to a
meet and greet and someone just comes
right up to taika like they know them i
would punch them in the [ __ ] face
yeah imagine if they grab tiger [ __ ]
kissed them and said i missed you taika
yeah you're like get the [ __ ] away i
don't even know who you are
yeah yeah like see you had a family
because like if i asked the whole tiger
oh yeah right yeah the fan kills oh can
i hold him would you be like no no
honestly i've turned on fans before i'm
like you look greasy dude
how do you say how do you turn them down
turn them down at the at what uh what
are the zoom beams
can i hold taika you're like man like
nah you're greasy as [ __ ]
you said that
some people don't know that they're
stank and grease
and bad hygiene yeah i'm like how the
[ __ ] are you gonna come to
a meet and greet with a t-shirt where
you bit the [ __ ] chin part
the neck part like an elementary school
student
it's all wrinkled up yeah i can
perfectly picture that
yeah well we had us the guy that we're
telling you that made like seven million
off of
bitcoin oh that guy dude he would walk
around with that and then
this would just be all wrinkly and like
wet and like dude what the [ __ ] are you
doing
he's a millionaire so yeah he had always
had dandruff yeah like
he washes harry once every three weeks
or something why he just didn't want to
shower
maybe that's how he became a millionaire
because he didn't shower and he saved
the money working all the time
he put that money into bitcoin that was
it i put my money into crypto too and
it's in
a different direction do you guys
believe in the whole crypto thing still
oh [ __ ] yeah dude what's up now
coming up yeah also certain coins just
got approved on the
coinbase yeah coinbase what everyone
trades on like makes it more authentic
and then those coins have been going up
and
yeah yeah you hear all that from steve
huh yeah i don't know [ __ ] about it
i'm just like reiterating everything
does he invest in crypto
for your household or does he invest it
for himself well there's a long story
but
he i gave him a budget from the family
budget
yes oh okay yeah so i managed our
finances because
of history and so
which we talked about on the money
masters program
are you talking about me managing your
master's or your masters of money
just give your money to your wife and
never manage it um no so yeah so he had
always been doing all kinds of research
on it he actually bought bitcoin
way back when um he he discovered it
when it was like
a couple dollars yeah but he didn't buy
it then he didn't buy until it went up
to a thousand dollars
still cheap which was still cheap yeah
um and then he got
super into bitcoin and because he writes
movies he gets paid
in like big chunks at a time so like he
might not get a paycheck for like the
whole year but then he gets paid this
huge amount of money yeah so anyway he
was expecting this huge chunk of money
and he was um like planning on buying it
buying it right at this point where it
was like there was a new coin that came
out that he did a lot of research on
he's like this is the next thing
and he's then he was getting super
depressed because his money was getting
behind and there's not like
a union that protects writers really
they get paid
but there's not really like any
protection for writers and writers or
like the lowest rung
and so yeah so it's taking forever for
this this movie to pay him
so he was getting really sad and we
weren't even married yet and i was like
i've been saving up for a house were you
about to be we talked about we were
engaged we were engaged
yeah we were engaged but we weren't
married yet like we weren't joined
financially yet
and um and so i gave him a chunk of
the deposit that i've been saving for a
house yeah and i was like here you
you know i trust you you've been doing
all your research so sweet here's this
to hold you over i was basically like
pay this deposit back
like when you get your check but then
that ended up blowing up
did you ever go in your face suck my
dick [ __ ]
no because i'm like the investor now
you're you're a shareholder of this
that's this investment yeah yeah no so
yeah that was a team effort though
yeah that's dope yeah so i was like you
can keep it in there that was a huge
come up though
yeah and then uh and then we put more
into it
and he's been going to different coins
and stuff and so
like yeah there's definitely like huge
ups and downs a lot of big downs that
scare people because it's much different
than the stock market
and i don't know a lot about it i just
know what he tells me and he's very
passionate about it so
um but like the downs are are like way
down because it's not like
regulated like the star stock market is
around it's kind of the wild and you
can't get bailed out like some of the
stocks
yeah yeah exactly and i'm down a quarter
mil but do you believe
if you believe in the technology that's
why i'm not sweating yeah exactly i
believe
and also you have to remember some of
these people that got in it's their
first time investing
it's their first time getting into
anything and they're getting into
something so [ __ ] volatile
yeah like yeah and there a lot of the
people
they got in less than six six months
they saw the up they saw the down and
they say
it's not gonna work and then they sold
those are called chumps
that's the professional term in in this
in the stock market all the time they're
suckers
yeah because the way people make money
is because the suckers
are buying when it's high and then they
[ __ ] sell when it's low
yeah and i heard all the suckers when we
went to the [ __ ] uh
barber shop oh you know we're getting
haircuts and they have these stupid ass
reasonings
man that's just not gonna work man
they're so stupid they're emotional
they're emotional investors and that's
basically what happens yeah so i mean
like
so went up that high in the beginning
and then it definitely came
down a lot and so people were like uh
like what do you think now
that like a lot of haters in the
cryptocurrency space because they're
like
they're just scared because like if
someone else succeeds then it's like oh
they made the wrong choice and not
stupid yeah and so it's definitely come
down but we're still way up you know
it's like
it's if you believe in the technology
which is what you should be doing anyway
even in the stock market you should be
investing
you should be researching the company
that you're investing in and believe in
that company
before you invest in that stock i think
that's the mistake people make because
if you
just start going based off like what you
heard was the next big stock thing or
whatever
then you're not actually doing your own
research and you're you're not being a
smart investor into a company
which is what a shareholder should be
i'm okay if they stay stupid because
that means less competition
that's true really i mean i'm not here
to prove anything to anyone
but if this was such a fake piece of
[ __ ] why is chase bank getting into it
and all these big
wall street hedge funds you know what i
mean the gains are [ __ ] good baby
if you go to east asia a lot of it is a
lot of them are converting over to
crypto yep too
like big companies too like mcdonald's
trying to go cashless in crypto too
completely yeah why is america so behind
on crypto then because that's
not regulated it's not regulated i've
seen i've seen like mcdonald's have
crypto in like france and all these
things right and then in asia and tokyo
right like
but i've never seen anything where you
can go up to a commercial
location right and go hey i have crypto
money well more than 60 percent of
american wealth
is made through investing banking all
this stuff right debt
debt so other countries that don't
really have this crazy
banking cartel they're not really
invested like the government's not
like trying to control the citizens to
continuously use
fiat and that [ __ ] so for them like
japan they have cash they're not a debt
society they're just like well [ __ ] it
we'll go
cashless we'll do all this stuff it
doesn't matter it'll work better we'd
have to print out [ __ ] paper
but the us we're heavily dependent on
investing in people being in debt all
this stuff it's a credit society
so if people stop using the banks and
stop doing all this stuff that's
less money going into that system so
they have a lot of lobbyists and all
that [ __ ] of course trying to like
dirty it's super dirty it's like how
they were trying to make it easier to do
your taxes and then like a bunch of
lobbyists for like
um h r block and [ __ ] like and turbo tax
stopped the bill from getting passed
because they need people to
not know how to do their taxes they
purposely
stop us from learning how to file taxes
do taxes learn
finances learn budgeting yeah we don't
even learn that in school you wouldn't
first place you would come across yeah
in economy you're just
learning the history of economy like
you're learning like
when monopolies became illegal yeah you
don't actually
learn how to manage money or invest or
any of the actual practical skills
right ridiculous it's crazy they don't
want you to win they don't want you to
but i do on jamalion academy
are you a money boy oh yeah no i'm a
money master
steve everyone else steve is a money
master everybody else
below us is a money boy or money what's
a money boy money girl
i'm a money girl oh yeah we had this
talk yesterday weren't you here for that
no he wasn't i thought we did
geo was here yeah yeah yeah so me and
steve came out with a special program
called the money masters mastering money
for the masters of money sounds awesome
so if you want to master money you have
to get with this money masters program
yeah the thing is
people are not yet mashes of money until
they go through the program
so they must be something so they're
money boys and girls
okay you at least one time in the
program what if they're called poor boys
reporting
i have the line uh money is a state of
mind because if not
let me help you out well uh we do have
another one called like money is
choice choices oh there you go there's
more choices
um yeah but maybe we'll get there we're
evolving we're still working i could
work with your brand team
yeah yeah yeah no and we got the guys
everyone
um we have a community going on we want
people to dress sharp post on their
instagram and put hashtag money boys and
money girls
last time yeah because the goal of a
money boy is to become a money master
and the goal for money girl is to marry
a money master what the girl can't
become a money master oh yeah she can
but i mean we're just trying to help her
increase her chances there's higher
chances of becoming higher chances
you're a money master and you also marry
a money master
that can't happen that can't happen yeah
i think so it's never happened before
it's never really happened
yeah so actually a real money master
would be a money girl that grew up to
marry a money master
and then she didn't they she made him
not sign a prenup and then she divorces
the money master and then she's a true
money master that's good yup that's
called a [ __ ] isn't it
a money [ __ ] she's a money master money
[ __ ] made the money synth
yup and there's yeah they're sim oh i
don't know if sims exist we don't want
them in our group
oh don't talk about it casey
you they wouldn't tell me yesterday if
we had we did a whole thing he's not
allowed to know about sims and i was
like what's a sin
no no okay this was i was gonna tell you
afterwards right
because we did a whole [ __ ] episode
because it's been a meme like okay we're
boomers we're sips and all that [ __ ]
right
wait boomers boomers are simple no no no
like it's kind of a meme boomer can be a
stamp
and a simp can be a boomer but they're
not one and they don't need to be the
same
weren't you here when we did the sim
video or our jk men's sims
has anyone done a theme that's like the
simpsons
no but we we got urban dictionary and
we basically read it out loud so the
definition of a set
you're not allowed to look up yeah we're
gonna tell them we're gonna tell them a
definition of a simp
is a man who puts a woman on the
pedestal to the point where he does
everything and anything for her and lets
her walk
all over him so he's basically a
pushover that's obsessed with her have
you seen him and hoping
every teenage boy yeah but also everyone
goes to a sim face oh okay
have you noticed that's the main insult
in cells used now online
same yeah they're just calling people
simple you know what's funny is i feel
like a lot of girls have been stimps too
though because
yeah a lot of us like just wait for the
text back you know we're just like
obsessed and waiting well because it's
uh it's uh
like get all dressed up and we're like
he's gonna text back and then you know
how many women take care of dudes that
don't even have a car or a job
or they just [ __ ] really good cells
to make fun of them
who happen to have girls wait what it's
a way for incels to make fun of guys who
happen to have girls oh yeah
it wouldn't work you can't call a girl a
simp
because that wouldn't work in that kind
of way to make themselves feel better oh
it's the same kind of haters that are
hating on cryptocurrency like when it
goes up they're like oh it's gonna go
down
all goes around you're such a zip
but i loved it though because i was like
so you love your woman
a lot and you want to take care of her
and you want to what's wrong with that
yeah it's just called the you lose your
man cause it's a healthy relationship
yeah well it's supposed to i guess in
their eyes it's a it's a you're a
doormat
oh the woman's doing like running the
show and stuff yeah i wonder how they
feel about old movies where the guy
takes off the trench coat
and puts it over the stamp they're like
that's the biggest thing
that's like literally damn physical form
what about the old movies where the guy
backhands the girl what is that called
uh
idea of a definition of a man is now
because that's really interesting yeah
because i want to add i want to
do it ask the incel oh let's ask
incel and then ask them like they would
have to admit that they're an insult for
you no they they take on that term
like a lot of people loudly take it off
i'm taking this on yeah
i am interested isn't it an online
identity though like i don't know if
they'll say that in real life
some do something as i didn't sell yes
there's some that like are open about
who they are and everything really
just bad talk women or you could frame
it as like um
a red pill like a man that knows the
truth and then
then when you put it out you're like ask
a simp is the brand
so they i'd like to know yeah i wonder
what people find like
what's defined as a man these days and
how different is it
just from 10 or even 20 or 30 years ago
because chivalry is considered slippery
it is wow like so you can't even open a
door for a lady anymore
so they watch it well isn't chivalry
like kind of a
structure for a code of conduct for like
genders to operate
like it's kind of like um like when you
had eating etiquette and all that stuff
like courtship yeah
literal chivalry yeah yeah and then
but then if they do open the door if
they don't open the door that's toxic
masculinity
so you lose but those are two different
crowds somewhere between being simple
same with gender toxic because if like
you want to be a housewife you're
ashamed but if you
by other women yeah and then because
you're like that career driven yeah and
then if you want to have a career then
you're shamed because you
don't want to raise your kids you're a
bad mom what about all the girls out
there
who want to be an accessory there are
yeah
i mean but i think that there should
just be an agreement among the two
partners
of what their roles are and then as long
as you do that then there's a lot you
don't think other people should be able
to comment on what that relationship is
yeah there's a freedom of speech are you
against freedom of speech you can
comment but
you're against freedom of speech how
unamerican i want to vote what goes on
in their relationship that's how they
sell you know my favorite [ __ ] is is
like
what you can't take criticism everyone
has the freedom to criticize
no one can take criticisms though if you
think about it but everything's all
labels and generalizations right
all men are this way all what do you
think about the men that do this and
it's like i think they're shitty
and i don't think they're men yeah like
i like people that write like paragraphs
about why you're
this type of person that they've branded
you as and they'll take like pieces from
each video and like out of context
and they'll piece together why you're a
simp or whatever and it's like wow you
really took a lot of time to like learn
about my life and
i judge that you just think about me a
lot
that's my goal in life is um i want to
imp
like i want to be in the people's brains
to the point where they obsess about me
and only think about me
so the whether it's hate or love or
obsession the more time they spend with
my
thoughts my like what i'm doing all that
stuff right i win because they're
wasting their time
and that means i get better at my life
you're living in their head rent free
yep that's what i'm saying i'm taking
that mental real estate girl
i've [ __ ] built a hotel you're
[ __ ] all over it yep and i created a
[ __ ] casino and a roller coaster ride
why do they turn crazy and stalk you
are they cute no they're not even girls
they're not girls they're cute guys are
they going to buy us programs later
yeah that's the real question yeah
because bart i was telling
one time i was like what was i was like
why should i respond to this guy and he
was like you should
you should tell them shut up and buy my
merch and i was like
that's one of the best responses i've
ever heard and i started saying that now
to people i've seen that in your
comments
they should buy it so they can hate on
it it's like shut up and buy my merch
[Laughter]
yeah but i don't know man i i kind of
like i like it all now i used to be like
oh i don't like any haters or
i just want all the supporters but now
i'm like
everyone and anyone the more they think
about me the more successful i become
that's true give me all because if they
think about you they're probably talking
about exactly
talking about they're also spreading the
good word brand awareness and there's 10
people that hate me and they're like you
know what
i need to see this for myself let me
investigate and they watch like 10 jk
news videos
so it's like yeah bring it [ __ ]
but i bet if you block them
they'll they'll obsess about you more
because they're like oh look it
they're thinking to me they blocked me
and then they'll create a new account oh
really
more views you should block people too
should i block all
people that follow me then yeah and then
they'll spawn five more
yeah so you get more views yeah yeah
that's what i am dude that is genius you
look at casey has zero followers
i just gotta wait you gotta wait it out
dude i cancelled myself guys
watch me go viral it's like pc it only
works when you block a handful man
you don't block your actual fans that
are casual dude now i feel like a synth
the simpsons right you should do it
[Music]
do
[Music]
you